let's talk about the narrative exploding
outside of the actual narrative
exploding we have this other story here
uh
alex berenson
so uh elon musk tweeted to alex berenson
a journalist can you say more about this
quote pressures that the government may
have placed on twitter
this is interesting alex barrison uh
berenson
was a uh is a journalist he was tweeting
about vaccines very skeptical and
talking about a lot of the data and then
he got suspended he filed a lawsuit
he won
nobody expected this to happen because
everyone believes that when you get
banned from twitter or whatever that you
file a lawsuit and then it gets thrown
out most of his suit did get thrown out
but breach of i think there was breach
of contract which persisted
so alex says i wish i could elon musk
but the settlement with twitter prevents
me from doing so however in the near
future i hope to hope and expect to have
more to report
on a substance post
talking about how he got his account
back he said
he says i need to add one thing the
settlement does not end my investigation
into the pressures that the government
may have placed on twitter to suspend my
account i will have more to say on that
issue in the near future i made a
promise to readers last month and i take
my promise promises to readers seriously
alex berenson
seems to have some kind of information
that the government is actively
pressuring twitter to engage in
censorship better watch out if elon musk
takes this company over it's going to be
really interesting to find out what
happens but how much do you want to bet
say it's october elon musk all the news
happens elon musk now owns twitter then
someone immediately says okay elon what
was going on and he goes i can't talk
about it how much do you want to bet
well if everyone i don't know how many
people read what he was talking about
last month but last month when uh he
discussed this on a sub stack he said
look i think we're getting close to an
agreement basically but any agreement i
make i promise will not exclude me
from being able to make this public
anything we may find in discovery
surrounding this issue and i think the
reason for that uh or why it's important
is because that gets to the crux of it
and we had those whistleblowers come out
with the disinformation government
bureau whatever they were calling it
where initially the government said they
weren't really policing everyone's
misinformation this was only going to be
targeting russian disinformation and
security stuff but that wasn't true
so if the government you know i'm not a
lawyer but if from what we hear from
others um and viva and robert talk about
this a lot this is the that's the
linchpin so if they were pressuring
these social media companies that opens
up a whole new
pandora's box
this is what really bugs me about a lot
of this is that uh alex filed
he made a first amendment claim
and the judge was like you have no first
amendment claim because it's private
company doing it not true we do know
there's a story out of california i
think it was judicial watch that exposed
us democrats were making requests on who
they wanted censored right these are
government actors going to a private
company and using them as a cudgel so we
need a court to come in on first
amendment grounds and we need that
information how do you navigate this
when we know they're doing it but the
courts are like well it's a private
company yeah it's like yes how do we get
the investigation to show the government
is going in and telling them to do these
things how do we get that information
i guess oh god a whistleblower is coming
out honestly
be brave go to project veritas yes or
some organization like veritas but
veritas is a great one yeah that's uh
chuck grassley senator grassley from
iowa how they how they got it there that
was government uh coming out and doing
that the private companies uh and
project veritas is a great if i was
working at one of those they would be at
the top of the list because they've been
doing so much of this
um but yeah i don't see any reason why
you couldn't go to a lawmaker as well i
mean eventually this has to be fixed
in the law the good news though
elon musk actively taking a role in
looking into these things
potentially
by october he may have twitter why do
you think by october that it was
reported that's when the settlement
should happen maybe even august so but
at some point soon i don't know it just
it just feels like people are clinging
to the idea and it's just not gonna
happen oh mary you're so wrong enough
elon musk will save us that's right
all of our faith in one's twitter jesus
that's right
i agree with you mary i think there's a
lot of like hope that he's going to save
us i don't think he cares i mean he's
just the guy and the government still
has gag orders like they can like you
said put a gag order they probably have
one on twitter right now that'll
transfer ownership it's on the company
so here's what i bet i bet there's a
national security letter the what i've
seen circulating is that the the feds
have national security interests in
stopping misinformation that's been the
idea that's going around if it's a
national security letter elon musk is
going to i'm going to buy this company
he's going to walk in and they're going
to be like here's what you've inherited
and he's going to look at it and go
can't do it can't do anything
and it's going to be the same exact game
so you were saying what's his name um
barrett barrister barrisser baron
alex berenson he said on a sub stack he
was going to go public with everything
he immediately it happened and then
when he said i made a promise to my
readers what he's talking about is that
he said i will not make an
a deal i will not whatever arrangement
we come to uh i will not agree to it if
it doesn't mean that i can't publicly
put out information relating to that uh
which
is important and then he agreed to a
deal and is no longer and he said he
can't put out publicly this is what got
me today so maybe it's a government his
settlement pro this this settlement
prevents uh settlement with twitter
prevents me from doing so yeah and this
is this is what got me today uh the
security angle is i don't know tim is
this is his twitter account really that
important it's got it's got to be that
though the this can maybe he thinks when
reading between the lines here he's
going to challenge that in court but
i'll tell you what if that's his plan
he's going to lose
he's going to lose without a doubt you
cannot beat those guys in court when
when they pull that national security
card that's it it's over it's done no
judge no federal judge is going to uh
is going to be you know one of the first
to do that that's the problem with
that's the first amendment
the first amendment argument that tim
was just lamenting they throw out all
the time that is the argument and they
toss it out uh you know all the time
they they throw that in the trash and
they talk about something that's on the
periphery or something and it just
drives me nuts i gotta i gotta call
shenanigans here
i gotta call shenanigans alex
shenanigans
your settlement with twitter
what
your twitter account that's it
did he get money
my understanding is got a twitter
account back
that's it we don't know the other
so i'm i'm sorry you yo
i'm going to give alex the benefit of
the doubt and just say this
it may be he's currently investigating
and doesn't want to ruin his ability to
get more information
but this is not enough to come out and
be like i got my twitter account back
guys i can't tell you about the
corporate malfeasance yeah i'm like uh
i'm hoping there's another i'm hoping
that you know what i would do
i would take a camera i would grab all
of the paperwork i would take a cigar i
don't smoke cigars either but i would
sit down at the camera on and be like
ladies and gentlemen everything i'm not
allowed to talk about and i'd throw it
down and be like i'm i'm over it i
wouldn't i don't i don't stand for that
now it's easy to say because i don't
know
what happened it could be a national
security letter
it could be that twitter said
look at what happened so so let me bring
this down for you
alex was told by an employee at twitter
that if he broke any of the rules they
would give him a warning
they banned him without giving him a
warning so he filed a breach of contract
first amendment and they said no no all
that stuff's out but the breach of
contract's legit because they said
they'd give you a warning they didn't
banned you okay they can't do that
and so twitter issued a statement saying
we should not have banned him for this
it could be that the reason he wasn't
given any warnings despite them saying
is because national security letter feds
came in and said ban him for saying
these things and twitter was like
whatever you say government
and then didn't tell him why
when when these people when a lot of
people get banned there's no reason
given
it happens it'll be like reason for band
blank yeah that's what happened to me
they may have gone to him and said we're
gonna tell you why you got banned we're
gonna reinstate you but you can't talk
about it if we do this do you agree yes
boom national security letter and then
he's like okay
i wonder if they could
i bet you they could justify
these issues they have with elections uh
you know claims about elections i wonder
if they could justify that under a
security banner as well
because you know i popped up 45 minutes
after tucker i was lucky and reinstated
but when i was banned it was boom it was
gone and the only thing they were
anticipating was a report that we were
releasing um whether some of the claims
that you saw on twitter after the
election you know this many of this
people voted this many of that people
voted uh we were doing an investigation
on it it was imminent it was coming and
i was sitting home watching television
with my kids and i got a text from steve
ben and he's like you're a legend you're
gone
are you what are you back on now though
i am i went on uh
yeah i'll tell you tucker it's the only
one i had in my back how long were you
were you banned for about two days two
days yeah it was an error or something
nope they just they totally ignored me
tim and i just reappeared i got off of
the show 45 minutes later you know i got
maybe 20 minutes at the opening at
tucker and maybe by nine o'clock 905 i
was just magically did you talk were you
talking about the ban on tucker
yes that's what he he called uh to have
me on to talk about it here's what
here's what i think so remember when
elon musk was like he's he secured the
deal and then all of a sudden all these
left accounts and celebrities lost
followers yeah tons of right wing and
libertarian accounts gained followers
i think it's obvious that there's some
kind of enron shenanin's going
shenanigans going on burning documents
destroying evidence something's
happening because they know elon's about
to come in
i think it involves the government
i think alex gave us that hint yeah just
that little teeny drop that he could say
without getting specifics and now he
can't say more because it involves the
government that could be taken out of
context and make it sound like you're
talking about alex jones about some
random thing yeah
the joke i posted is uh there's a video
going viral showing like who's that is
it bugs yeah who's that fat comedian oh
no anna ferris james james they're
eating crickets and ants and stuff
that's gross and then they're like uh i
just saw that and i was like the year is
2037. alex jones is sworn in as
president his first act is to as an
executive order turning all the frogs
straight that's right but my you know
the joke is just
they show you these videos of people
eating bugs and i think people are gonna
go and vote for trump yeah joe biden all
he needs to do to lose is come up and be
like come on man vote for me and you'll
be eating crickets people are going to
be like okay
i don't want to do that i think it's a
safe maybe not assumption but a safe
consideration that the government is
involved because it's twitter it's a
huge social media company they come in
with cease and desist orders they come
in with gag orders they say you need to
ban this person you're legally obligated
not to ever mention any anything about
this ever so they'll give the person a
no reason ban
and a story i was talking to this guy uh
when i was in austin
and he said i i think we're gonna have
him on the show he worked for the
government he worked in the trump
administration and he said
the view of the national security
apparatus is that the meme stuff and
donald trump was undermining our
national security and must be stopped
and so what their goal is they want to
make the right present but politically
ineffective
cause just enough damage to the right so
they they can be present look like
they're putting up a fight but lose
because if you come in and just outright
ban everybody it creates ripples and
destabilizes the system so they're
trying to make it a 4951 scenario so the
democrats just slightly win every time
but it looks like the republicans are so
close yeah it disrupt equilibrium a
little bit and just make it a
that but that's the way it is in the
media right now i mean they almost have
and i say this uh
you know i use this analogy really i
don't know if anybody plays pool but
it's almost like that i would completely
expect that because it's almost like
democrats have this advantage everywhere
else whether it's the media the
pollsters whatever um you know it's like
you're playing a game of pool with
somebody they want the six
if you don't spot them to six uh they
put a you know they they have a canary
or don't want to play the game at all
it's like they have this built-in
advantage um and when it comes to
messaging they lost that in 2016. and
their major lesson that they learned
from all of this was not that there are
people out there who have grievances
those grievances are legitimate maybe we
should listen to them that was not their
lesson the lesson they took from this
was let's control information we lost
control of the information flow those
memes i i've heard they take those
series they were effective
yeah donald trump was memed into the
presidency thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there